con nuestro primer invitado al día vamos
a hablar del Salvador donde el
presidente nayib bukele aseguró que en
60 días estará lista la mega cárcel en
donde se encerrarán a unos 40.000 de los
pandilleros detenidos en el marco de una
guerra que les declaró su gobierno el
reclusorio se construye alejado de las
ciudades y también está rodeado de
tierra propiedad Estatal con varios
niveles de muros y 37 Torres de
vigilancia además el congreso del
Salvador de amplia mayoría oficialista
aprobó una cuarta ampliación del régimen
de excepción vigentes de finales de
marzo que ha dejado más de 46.600
detenidos y miles de denuncias de
violaciones a los Derechos Humanos según
bukele se está cerca de ganar la guerra
contra las pandillas con este régimen de
excepción que suspende varios derechos
constitucionales incluido el de la
defensa saludamos entonces a nuestro
pueblo invitado él es Rafael Domínguez
analista político y periodista
independiente Gracias Rafael por estar
con nosotros en directo América de
Francia 24 muy buen día y le pregunto
primero que a las implicaciones sociales
que tiene esta construcción de esta mega
cárcel con ella además llega el fin de
problema de las pandillas en El Salvador
Buen día Raúl Saludos a toda esta
importante audiencia Pues bueno
efectivamente lo que sucede El Salvador
mantiene expectativa por cuanto en una
parte del resultado posible en la guerra
contra las pandillas si el otro el
efecto que tiene
lograr esto a través de la violación
sistemática de la Constitución y de
otras leyes y por supuesto la violación
de Derechos Humanos Esa es la El dilema
la situación que enfrenta hoy El
Salvador Buscar por un lado Un fin
importante que todos deseamos que sea
positivo y por otro eh que esto se dé a
través de la instalación de un estado de
represión y de la sostenibilidad en el
tiempo de un estado que tiene por ahora
restrictivos
derechos humanos para buena parte de la
población donde sea estén matizado a la
prensa donde hay falta de información
donde hay una difícil situación para
poder sostenerlo en el tiempo si
hablamos en términos económicos también
está una inversión millonaria en una
cárcel para 40.000 personas que son más
o menos los capturados hasta la fecha en
estado de detención provisional
prolongado por el estado de excepción y
que todavía no tienen un proceso
judicial no tienen toda la garantía de
un proceso justo y veremos qué pasa
cuando este estado de excepción termine
esté lista la cárcel y todos estos
procesos lleguen a juicio lo decías
ahorita Rafael las denuncias de las
violaciones de los Derechos Humanos
también
violaciones a unos derechos
constitucionales con este régimen de
excepción además también ongs y
detractores al gobierno del presidente
en el YouTube bukele dicen que en esta
cárcel se pudieran cometer torturas
digamos de qué violaciones de Derechos
Humanos estábamos hablando y también que
violaciones constitucionales se han
cometido en este régimen de excepción y
que si finalmente pues lo que dice
también la prensa y Ana los políticos en
su país Le quiero preguntar si este
régimen de excepción se va a acabar
finalmente con esta construcción de la
megacárzal digamos cuando estos 40.000
personas esta empresas hay se planea el
gobierno digamos que puede ampliar este
régimen de excepción para seguir
haciendo pues lo que ellos consideran
que está bien bajo las políticas
ejecutivas de bukele
Pues el gobierno salvadoreño parece que
no tiene otro camino si quieres sostener
esta lucha tendrá que hacer uso del
estado de excepción o el régimen de
excepción lo cual viola la Constitución
porque deja de ser excepcional y se
convierte en algo permanente es una
contradicción en sí misma porque no
logra sin este proceso realmente
sostener la lucha contra las pandillas
lo que lleva a la gran pregunta si
realmente Entonces está haciendo
totalmente efectivo pero el gobierno se
ha comprometido en sostenerlo para
garantizar el resultado frente a la
población que tiene años clamando el
cese de los homicidios el cese de las
extorsiones el cc de las pandillas en en
los territorios sin embargo también Esto
no es que ha cesado 100% el gobierno
maneja a sus estadísticas publicita la
la los días de ser homicidios pero en
las calles la gente sabe que las cosas
no han cambiado al 100% entonces uno
aquí se qué tan eficiente va a hacer
esto y qué tanto en el tiempo entonces
el régimen va a mantenerse para poder
ser efectivo Se violan derechos entonces
constitucionales porque en sí mismo
sostener el estado de excepción por
largo tiempo ya es una violación
constitucional y por otro lado las
restricciones a la garantías procesales
a la garantías constitucionales que este
régimen le le le le da a los que son
detenidos que son trasladados a un
régimen excepcional también en espera de
su proceso jurídico porque le dan una
detención instantánea de seis meses para
garantizarle a la fiscalía que pueda
investigar y presentar pruebas la gran
pregunta Entonces es si después de seis
meses o hasta que esté la cárcel que era
lo que tú mencionaba Raúl ese no se sabe
a ciencia cierta no se sabe también si
efectivamente en 60 días se va a
terminar una mega obra tan compleja como
la que se está presentando por lo tanto
no tenemos exactamente cuando Esto va a
finalizar y el resultado que en el
tiempo dejará para los salvadoreños
también el presidente bukele Rafael dice
que con esto se está llegando al fin de
la guerra contra las pandillas también
habían unas denuncias que esta este
incremento digamos de la violencia en El
Salvador por parte de las pandillas
habría sido producto de una ruptura de
palabra al presidente bukele con las
pandillas luego de llegar al poder que
hay sobre todo este relación También con
el gobierno bukele con las pandillas con
este supuesto acuerdo y también pues si
realmente se está llegando al fin de la
guerra con las pandillas de una manera u
otra
bueno Raúl En definitiva todos los
salvadoreños queremos que se termine el
problema de las pandillas que vino
creciendo en los últimos años y se
convirtió realmente en un problema sin
embargo la forma en la que se esté
realizando tampoco garantiza que esto ha
terminado el presidente dice Esta es la
forma sin embargo esto no estaba en los
planes gubernamentales esto no estaba en
la oferta electoral Esto no se veía
venir lo que sí sabemos se había dado
era de alguna manera acuerdos con las
pandillas para reducir las extorsiones
reducir los asesinatos y después de una
ruptura en ese proceso esto te lo digo
por publicaciones que se han hecho en
los medios de comunicación al respecto a
audio de funcionarios del gobierno del
presidente bukele que han dado pie a
creer que este acuerdo se rompió y por
lo tanto pasó de un acuerdo a una
recriminación completa a para llevarlas
hasta la cárcel y ahora el propósito es
encarcelar Se supone a 80.000 posibles
miembros de pandillas y la situación no
sabemos en qué va a derivar por ahora
hay una paz hay una tranquilidad
relativamente mucho más grande de la que
nunca se había logrado en los
territorios pero la gran expectativa o
la gran pregunta es si esto realmente es
ese fin en la lucha contra las pandillas
O solamente es una pausa una situación
que luego derivará en más complicaciones
jurídicas en más complicaciones incluso
de violencia en los territorios cuando
muchos de estos que ahora son capturados
van a salir o no sabemos qué más va a
suceder si serán juicios sumarios y si
inmediatamente van a pasar todos
directamente a la cárcel Lo cual sería
también un proceso a evaluar
posteriormente